okay let's say we're gonna go back to
your high school virginia beach
and you are going to have a five minute
pow wow with some students
on the first steps of making a movie
what would you tell them
when i was making shorts with my friends
when i was 17 18 i was having fun
i mean it was work but it didn't you
don't think of it that way nobody did i
don't think
so you should have fun and you should
you know think of an idea or something
that you
mean something to you personally that's
that's different not just uh
you know because a lot of young
filmmakers they just imitate other
movies that they've seen they do their
own version of that and i did things
like that too
but i think if you're gonna like really
put some effort into something nowadays
you you know maybe try to think of an
idea a story line a little short story
that you know
has some kind of meaning to you
personally it isn't to be the most like
biggest heavy theme in the world but
just something that means something to
you
and also try to do something simple and
start off with something simple
uh because if you try to do a bigger
thing right off the bat it's it's gonna
you know it could turn into a mess so i
think you know and usually the really
the really good short films
the best ones i'm talking about the top
of the you know they're usually fairly
simple with a lot not too many
characters
and a fairly straightforward story and
some kind of a surprise at the end some
kind of a twist at the end
you know that kind of stays in your mind
so those are some of the things i would
say i mean i just think you but i think
you should have fun doing it i think
that's that's very important don't worry
too much about the technical aspect
of it i think you know you will learn
that over time if you're serious about
it if you're in and you might even have
other people doing those
those jobs but initially i think you
should just think more about
conveying something original you know
idea-wise i would say and then would it
be the same if it was for features let's
say you're
speaking to a group of high school
students who've been making short films
since they were like eight
and so now they're ready to make this
leap would be the same
or any other advice geez you know it's
it's funny i mean like the first feature
i did i was 17 when i directed
it was a vampire hitman movie
called bad blood and it was just so
influenced by
you know john woo the killer and you
know probably some horror movies i was
watching at the time and
so it wasn't the most original thing in
the world uh and it was biting we were
definitely biting off a lot more than we
could shoot we had all these big action
scenes and effects and stuff so it would
be tough for me to tell people don't do
that
you know like it'd be tough for me to
tell people don't be ambitious
with your future because i don't know i
feel like a lot of the a lot of major
filmmakers who start off making shorts
and things like that they were pretty
ambitious with their projects
so i don't know i mean i think you i
think it does just boil down like the
short film it kind of boils down to
coming up with an idea that you're
really passionate about and a story
you're really passionate about
and something you feel realistically you
can achieve
you know with your resources that you
have but it's always good to push a
little bit more beyond that
like i still do that now like anytime i
come up with an idea for something i
want to make
i always think to myself okay what are
we what resources do we have
okay great now let's push another 10
another 20 percent
how much 30 however much percent we can
push it
because i feel like if you're not doing
that then
you're not challenging yourself enough
you're not like
that's to me that's the excitement is
always pushing beyond a bit beyond your
budget beyond your
resources because then you come up with
cool
creative things sometimes like cool
creative
solutions for those things do you know
what i mean
that's that's what i would say
interesting because do you think
has it always been been in you to not
play it safe or were you always groomed
to play it safe
i might have been groomed to play it
safe but i don't think i did
i mean if i mean if i did i wouldn't
make any movies i wouldn't
pick up a camera and even bother with it
and because these things were definitely
not
safe i mean sometimes there were literal
safety issues you know with
we're you know trying to do gun fights
and we're setting off
firecrackers you know using firecrackers
as squibs and
you know we we we got you know taken
home by the cops more than a few times
you know
we're filming these things and kicked
out of locations and
we didn't get arrested or booked but
just
close to that as close as you can get to
that uh
so no i was definitely not playing it
safe and i and i've always had this in
you know mentality and sometimes it's
got me into trouble
where i'll go into something that's very
low budget and in my mind is some big
100 million dollar movie
like my mind you know i'm making a movie
for a million dollar movie and my mind
is like aliens
you know or something that's 100 million
why can't we just do that why can't we
just do that stuff well because we're on
the money i don't want to hear that
i just want to try to do something with
that level of intensity and
and everything so it's it's uh i've
always kind of been like that i always
kind of
push beyond the boundaries i think in
terms of the the resources
and stuff um that's that's the fun of it
you know going back to paul schrader i
know we were just having fun talking
about it off camera but
you were just you had something to say
about just his work and being
appreciated
well i think what okay i'm a huge paul
schrader fan i've been a
fan since i discovered his work while i
was in film school
and i'm a fan of not just the movies
he's written but the movies he's
directed which
are the ones that people i think really
need to see
the first reformed he got his first
oscar nomination for first reformed
this past you know oscars and he didn't
win but
i was number one surprised that that was
the first oscar nomination he'd ever
received for
considering he's written you know movies
like taxi driver and raging bull i was i
was
i consider my straight myself a
straighter expert and i thought he had
at least been nominated for those movies
my
point though where i was thinking you
know was this
thing about first reform which is on a
lot of critics top 10 lists and all that
is you never you never really count
anybody out
you know paul schrader is someone who i
think has been counted out
more than once in his career i think
he's been
i don't say the butt of jokes but i
think he's definitely been you know
downgraded not really appreciated as a
filmmaker
and even recently especially with some
of the stuff that he
directed and i think it's just great
that
he made that film it's very much of a
schrader film
it's very pure schrader movie and even
if i didn't like it as much as some of
his other work i still just was so happy
to see that and i think it just proves
that nobody's ever
out you know no filmmaker is ever
retired
or done because you never know what they
might come up with next
so that's what i yeah and that's really
what i thought i mean and other people
did too
you know and when you had friends that
went to film school
that kind of said like i wouldn't do
that or don't do that or that's stupid
or why would you
do was that sort of in your mind just
seeing how
someone's work or someone can be doubted
at first and underappreciated do you
think you
i think i've i think i've reached the
point because i've been directing
now for 20 plus years
i've reached the point that you know
i've had my own ups and downs
just like a lot of other filmmakers and
it puts you it gives you a perspective
on things
and you you are more you you are more
understanding of those type of like ups
and downs and shifts that every
filmmaker has in their career
so like the thing with schrader you know
to me it was just sort of like a nice
proof it happens with actors a lot
sometimes but you don't see it as much
with like
directors or writers you know sometimes
you'll you know what i mean that kind of
that kind of thing that kind of rebirth
or that kind of revitalized thing
sometimes you'll you know see that but
um
no i don't know i just i just think that
i'm not i'm not
regretful of any anything you know what
i mean
i think people it's these are people to
make fun of stuff sometimes when they're
you know they're not doing it or
whatever it's always easier it's always
easier to not make a movie than to make
a movie
you know and it's interesting how the
crowd turns
can turn on somebody who can have like
three great movies in a row and man they
do one movie it's not even that it's
like
a beautiful subject matter and then
people are so angry
two of my two of my favorite directors
william fritkin peter bogdanovich
that's exactly what happened to both of
them i mean freaking on the
even bigger level because he had you
know french connection the exorcist and
you know you don't get bigger and more
popular than those films uh then he did
sorcerer
which everyone just loved to hate even
though it's not a bad film in fact i
think it's his best film
and a lot of people have come around and
he considers it his best film too
by the way a lot of people consider that
his best work or definitely one of his
best movies
and i think people were just looking for
him to fail
like they're kind of wanting him to fail
at that point like okay buddy you've had
your turn
you're done now you know that's that's
that's how i perceived it
bogdanovic is the same with you know uh
with the last picture show and what's up
doc and all that and then he
you know kind of couldn't wait to sort
of you know have this big downward
and i'm not look i'm not saying that all
everything you know all these
everything they directed was brilliant
but
there's this there is a tendency yeah to
kind of like put somebody way up on a
pedestal and then tear them down
way down uh way way lower than they
than they deserve you know yeah it seems
like that's part of almost
some career paths and then there's a
rebuilding and a rebirth but
like years later different people i mean
like you know like i was mentioning
friedkin he's another one that you know
he's some of the films he's made lately
and i think he's in his 80s now
or late 70s or 80s or some of his best
films
i mean i thought bug was a tremendous
movie and it's a very small movie you
know
and and i thought killer joe was really
good and these are like recent films
that he directed
and he's had a lot of peaks and valleys
i actually find filmmakers like that
a lot more interesting than like
directors like sorry but people like
spielberg
who are pretty much coasting along and
yeah sure he's got some ups and downs
but like
he's never been vilified the way some of
these
other filmmakers were talking about and
you know he's never had probably such
box office
you know losses and you know incredible
and he's never worked on such a small
level either like a movie like bug or um
or killer joe or something like that you
know so
i just i find directors like that more
interesting i think a lot of my favorite
filmmakers are
kind of eccentric and they're not
mainstream
necessarily very few actually are
you know
you